кредиты долги как от них избавляться
имеют прямое отношение кредитам была
должна 500 тысяч долларов в трем банкам
95 тысяч долларов кредитного лимита У
тебя есть мнимые ощущения что у тебя
есть Эти деньги я просто потреблять
начал зарплату раздали аренду заплатили
пойдем покушаем
кредит на покупку жилого дома Я у этого
банка был крупнейший заемщик
помогает
сегодня скажите про послание что вы
думаете Хорошо или плохо
[музыка]
приветствовать вас на нашем втором
сезоне
[музыка]
от наших подписчиков наших зрителей и
сегодня выходим с очень интересной Темой
это кредиты и долги и как от них
избавляться
но в то же время имейте ввиду что если
вам интересны какие-то другие темы то не
стесняйтесь писать в комментариях те
темы которые вас интересуют а также
пишите пожалуйста тех людей которых вы
хотели бы чтобы мы пригласили на Агент
подкаст еще чем знаменателен этот гемба
подкаст это тем что с этого выпуска мы
открыты для рекламного сотрудничества с
нашими спонсорами И у нас появился
первый генеральный спонсор это компания
Марин хелс с продуктом кардиомарин
примечательность этой компании в том что
я знаю Лично основатель этой компании и
они доставляют в Казахстан добавки
произведенные в Японии А как вы знаете я
очень неравнодушен к Японии японской
философии и японскому качеству
благодаря этим биодобавкам и это
биодобавка кардиомарин она для
профилактики сердечно-сосудистых
заболеваний И тромбов кстати у этой
компании у компании Marin Health есть
целая линейка биодобавок Поэтому если
интересно можете пройти по ссылке
которую мы дали внизу и там вы на сайте
можете посмотреть описание и купить
любую добавку которая вам понравится Я
лично пользуюсь добавками компании
[музыка]
Итак мы начинаем наш подкаст
Добрый вечер друзья Итак мы начинаем
второй сезон нашего гемба подкаста и
сегодня тема сегодняшнего нашего герба
подкаста это кредиты долги как от них
избавляться Как правильно брать кредиты
Ну если будет даже такие такой опыт и
будет рассказаны истории вообще все что
касается Долгов кредитов давать кому-то
в долги брать у кого-то брать кредиту
банка брать на бизнес на личное
потребление стоит не стоит на проведение
тоев на там покупку смартфонов машин или
на бизнес в какой валюте и так далее это
все вот этот весь клубок проблем мы
попробуем обсудить Мы конечно же
понимаем что Полтора часа времени
отведенное нам будет недостаточно Ну это
не вопрос опять-таки
исчерпать всю тему у нас формат такой
собрались единомышленники друзья Ну мы
собрались не в кафешке А вот за столом
гемба подкаста и пообсуждаем поделимся
каждый своим опытом и своим видением А
по ходу если у вас возникнут какие-то
лайфхаки или какие-то если наши советы
Вам помогут вашей жизни мы будем только
рады и еще раз хочу заметить такую вещь
если вас интересует какие-то темы
просьба писать в комментариях эти темы
мы обязательно их рассмотрим как темы
будущих наших подкастов и обязательно
пишите кого бы вы хотели бы пригласить
чтобы мы пригласили на подкаст Итак
традиционно мы начинаем с представления
участников начнем слева направо
традиционно у нас участники
представляются сами и так Илья
Всем добрый вечер Меня зовут Ильяс
исатаев Я предприниматель У меня три
проекта Первый проект по которым многие
из вас меня знают Это сеть фитнес-клубов
invictus Fitness сегодня 12 клубов уже
работают по Казахстану и в следующем
году будет уже около 20 второй бизнес
это it компания it-компания тоже
работает около фитнес-индустрии Половина
времени они занимаются обслуживанием
потребностей Виктор фитнеса но также в
рамках it-проекта У меня есть новый
проект называется Heroes journey мы его
сейчас Тестируем и если все пойдет по
плану Через пару лет будем пытаться
вывести на зарубежный рынок третий
бизнес это управление инвестициями
инвестициями
вкладываемся в американские акции по
принципу валентности
Всем доброго времени суток Меня зовут
Кайрат мендегалиев Я являюсь серийным
предпринимателем Как сейчас модно это
говорить так как несколько направлений
бизнеса розничные продажи и услуги
компания rcatel это мобильные смартфоны
и электроника
уходовая косметика компания коко на 40
бутиков по Казахстану в торговых центрах
10 городах также являюсь владельцем
франшизы минисона Западный Казахстан и
недавно приобрели французы наши пицца
пиццерии
Кроме этого в Астане у нас боулинг
комплекс
как раз как раз вот у нас Эксперт в
плане потребительского кредитования по
при покупке смартфонов мы как раз
поговорим сегодня с тобой об этом
[музыка]
Грата International Мы работаем в 20
странах
единственным казахстанское юридическая
фирма которая до такого масштаба выросла
Я работаю на юридическом рынке
Казахстана 18 лет больше уже даже
занимаюсь так или иначе разными
проектами связанными с инфраструктурой
целиком проектами крупными строительными
проектами и немножко пишу в соцсетях
классно
у него классный аккаунт очень классные
посты пишет
фирма Грата Да действительно очень
известная старейших в Казахстане
основатель компании
Всем добрый вечер Я Шолпан по себетова
основатель ресурсного центра адамант где
мы помогаем людям раскрыть их сильные
стороны также руководитель дивизиона
Запад мультибрендовой компании центр
International Я в этой компании 22 года
и наш регион Запад сегодня Топ в мире
имею прямое отношение кредитам самый
такой кейс была должна 500 тысяч
долларов банкам 10 лет отрабатывала и
благодаря знаниям закрыла за два с
половиной года
как раз об этом тоже поговорим сегодня
вы расскажете
Yes Добрый вечер друзья Меня зовут
диаспоргожин являюсь генеральным
директором совладельцем сети ресторанов
Руми центре вкусного плова вот наша
компания более 7 лет вот у нас 5
ресторанов в двух городах еще одна
столовая вот
родом с Павлодара дочка классно Итак все
наши гостиные гости представились Вы
наверное уже имеете общее представление
Кто сидит в этой аудитории я уверен и
сто процентов у каждого из вас есть
истории связанные с кредитами Для начала
я дам коротенькую статистическую справку
[музыка]
вы хотите закредитованность в целом
населения огромное но я сразу забегая
вперед скажу такой спойлер это на самом
деле не худший показатель в мире и в
мире есть страны гораздо более
закредитования Но те же США взять они
тоже эти брать на душу населения и к ВВП
то они более закредитованы но в целом
надо учитывать что у них и возможности
зарабатывать больше Поэтому если
учитывать относить сумму кредитов к ВВП
или на душу населения и способность
этого населения генерить доходы то
конечно
сравнение в нашу пользу до того как мы
перейдем к этой теме Я хотел бы чтобы
разрядить обстановку сегодня президент
только хорошую тему для обсуждения
честно говоря
сегодняшнего послания но вкратце
потому что все мы жители этой страны и
нас непосредственно коснется все что
сегодня пока я сказал Давайте У кого
какой мне сегодня скажите про послание
ваше мнение что вы думаете Хорошо или
плохо и так далее и желающие
Нет я не могу сказать то что я полностью
еще не смотрел Не смотрел а значит я
неправильно поставил вопрос надо начать
с того кто смотрел давайте начнем с
этого кто смотрел послание
Точнее я читал полную расшифровку
смотреть не смотрю на сайте
[музыка]
лучше с плюсов
это то что впервые в нашей стране
на таком высоком уровне
там ряд миро предложил они там очень
много Конечно в исполнении в конечном
итоге убраться но факт тот что упомянул
он это вот я надеюсь что в этом плане
что-то начнет двигаться Ну и второй
момент наконец-то что-то начинают делать
вроде как сундуком в плане приватизации
вот и опять же это опять лет пять об
этом говорится лет наверное даже 2011
году я работал над первым проектом
народного опиу как юрист То есть это уже
с того времени тянется как бы каждый раз
когда эта тема поднимается хочется чтобы
я наконец довели до конца на уровне
приватизации на уровне избавления от
монополий на уровне нормальной рыночной
конкуренции там в сферах ж/д
и других
розничный налог
планировали вообще убрать и повысить до
шести процентов
в принципе это прогрессивный налог в
налог в плане того что еще его называют
налог на потребление и в этом логический
смысл есть то есть чем больше ты
потребляешь тем больше должен платить
налогов в этом Да есть положительный
плюс еще кто смотрел но мне было
интересно что налог на роскошь налог
на роскошь Здесь вопрос но я сегодня уже
высказал свое мнение
то что я читал
автомобильные других стран то что детей
будут деньги оплачивать налог розничный
то есть вот такие такие плюшки классные
которые Все хотели слышать и получили но
в то же время изменения опять в
Конституции выборы и вот здесь вопрос
это специально или это действительно вот
эти плюшки мы получим и страна будет
развиваться а касаемо вопроса изменение
Конституции
ну причем что плюшки мы получим как бы
не сразу
выборы будут сразу и вот эта схема
плюшки в обмен на выбор и мне кажется
она немножко такая такая немножко от
лукавого такая хитрая схема Ну так или
иначе Если говорить о Вот вот этой
инициативе семилетнем сроки во-первых
есть аналоги
долгий
единичный президентский срок есть из
развитых стран например в Южной Корее
При этом надо отметить тот интересный
факт что по моему в отношении четырех
президентов Южной Кореи сейчас заведено
уголовные дела постоянно
технологии
нормальных странах другое дело что
сейчас Получается что при любом даже
самом скромном подсчете у нас опять есть
президент который будет править 11 лет
2019 по 2030 и не является ли
повторением ошибок
больше народ поддержал бы мне так
кажется но в целом
в целом как Оцените позитивно негативно
я выскажу к новому Казахстану я отношусь
очень нейтрально потому что он начался в
очень
тяжелая ситуация в январе этого года да
И
если даже говорить что то что было в
январе было очень плохо да и так далее
Все равно найдется очень много людей
которые спорят это точка зрения скажет
но если бы этого не было было бы уже
хуже было бы гораздо хуже с этим тоже
трудно не согласиться моя позиция это
подождать чуть-чуть
как и многие здесь я лично в политике
абсолютно никакого интереса не имеют
многие следят за этим То есть такие же
послания было 10 лет назад
добавить потому что смотрите в целом в
целом позитивный настрой народа это
очень важно в целом потому что Один плюс
один это два в математике а в бизнесе в
семье в обществе это 11 это Синергия
если мы все будем позитивно думать Вот
эта энергия наших праведных мыслей она
все равно очень сказывается сказывается
А если мы каждый негативного ожидания
будем это может сказаться знаете хуже
когда Вроде я добрый но добра никакого
не сделала спрятался за дверью и ожидаю
А когда ты мыслями думаешь что Это
правильное послание что ты где-то можешь
помочь президенту своему да Или на своем
уровне что ты можешь полезно сделать
обществу если Каждый из нас будет так
думать
мне кажется наше общество быстрее
превратится в новый Казахстан
еще учесть надо что
конъюнктура в нашу пользу если брать все
страны СНГ все-таки Казахстан на самых
последних позициях и в этом плане если
раньше мы как-то равнялись на другие
страны то сейчас начинают равняться
наносить и с одной стороны начинаешь
думать Может быть Вот это наша
серединная линия она не такая плохая как
нам представлялась до этого нам же все
время хочется все в идеале чтобы
идеальная демократия сразу пришла
идеально Свобода пришла и так далее но в
то же время наши власти всё время
пытаются где-то серединку держать не
давать
Можно добавлю Я согласен насчет
оптимизма вот
до Нового Казахстана
у многих людей вокруг был абсолютно
пессимизм
В какой момент я перееду в Америку
сейчас какой-то
оптимизм есть
и еще экономика в этом году случайным
образом очень сильная Давайте на этой
веселой ноте остановимся у меня на самом
деле оптимизма было больше после
послания стало меньше Но все равно это
не так чтобы в негативную сторону ушло
просто оптимизм стало меньше Но это не
значит что я теперь негативно настроен
[музыка]
Давай переходим к нашей к нашим баранам
к нашей теме это кредиты у нас сегодня
вопрос стоит большие темы это
потребительские кредиты это кредиты для
бизнеса это ипотека давайте наверное
сначала расскажем расскажем у кого Какая
история была связана с кредитами а потом
будем обсуждать это зло или не зло там
или как погашать кредиты как вообще из
долговой ямы выбираться поэтому сначала
делимся личной историей были у вас
ситуации когда у вас были кредиты и вы
не могли погасить или вы взяли и
благополучно вышли Итак
В общем история такова что я в 95 году
вернулась в декретного отпуска и моей
организации не было То есть СНГ уже не
было та улица с Казахстан и моя
организация тоже не было потому как
женщина быстро гибко реагирует Я вышла
на рынок
стала значит продавать и у меня два
образования один из них с высшим и я в
продажах ориентируюсь за три года мы
быстро поднялись за три года концу
третьего года у нас был четырехуровневый
дом в дуке напротив Абая правда рынок
был большой магазин сейчас
он назывался
и во всех рынках были точки и большая
база была мы продавали алкогольную
продукцию которая быстро поднимается я
была одним из первых индивидуальных
предпринимателей которые работают со
всеми заводами и через три года когда мы
прямо до полутора миллиона долларов
довели оборот все было хорошо нам
поступило предложение от партнера с кем
мы постоянно работали это
за 90 продавали за 120 и все у нас
хорошо
за все все наше имущество поставить
залог и выдать нам невероятное
количество вино-водочной продукции но
оформить это деньгами вот тут моя
юридическая неграмотность Я согласилась
Ну какая разница я покупаю Да А так мне
без денег дают мои имущество и мы взяли
невероятное количество Мы даже не знали
куда эту алкогольную продукцию ставить
мы на рынках торговали товар шел и
буквально через полтора-два месяца
объявляется сухой закон
То есть это было спланированная акция и
я не знаю куда даваться во всех рынках
запрещать на лодочную продукцию
продавать я не знаю я бегу туда
руководителю завода Я тогда не знала
и говорю как мне быть Они говорят Ну
знаете наш торговый дом по 45 тенге Я
говорю как в 45 я же А где мне закрывать
как кредит у меня большой кредит они
говорят А вы деньгами Прокрутите
опять-таки юридическая неграмотность не
подкованность еще ну как бы финансовая
неграмотность Я иду на поводу То есть я
доверилась тем людям с кем я приличное
время отработала То есть у нас были уже
очень доверительные отношения и таким
образом
я потеряла все вот все и мы здесь не
остались можно сказать на улице
преимущество Все забрали но кредиты
остались и обязательства перед
поставщиками остались и вот я с этим
жила 10 лет 10 лет я жила Я очень много
работала и я платила ежемесячный взнос
тогда 90 года же процентные ставки
намного выше были я платила их мы еще
взяли под проценты ну это же банковский
процент и тогда они были высокие высокие
еще я свою квартиру тоже как бы взяла
как бы под кредит и в ипотеку и
получается все эти 10 лет их
отрабатывала ежемесячный взнос А вот сам
основной долг Он не уменьшался
деньги банка
у тебя такой груз есть
и вот 53 года мне было сейчас мне 60 и
вот 7 лет тому назад я получила мощную
мощность знания о финансах вообще о
финансах что я вообще неправильно живу
что у меня полный хаос в деньгах и я
стала по этой системе жить за два с
половиной года закрыла Я помню я
расписала план на сто лет и в этом плане
было с 13 по 20 закрытие 500 тысяч
долларов прям расписано было но 16 году
11 февраля я домой принесла три бумаги с
трех банков где было написано ваш кредит
погашен ваш кредит погашен ваш кредит
погашен но кредиты для меня оказали еще
как бы положительную роль они для меня
как возможность у меня появился новый
навык зарабатывать деньги Да я там
изменила мышление от должника к богатому
человеку мышление богатого человека
мышление победителя мышление миллионера
Потом я сократилась все ненужные расходы
изменила стратеги увеличение дохода
изменилась своей привычки То есть я
изменилась Я стала новой Шолпан
соответственно у меня появился мощный
навык зарабатывания денег и когда клиент
закрылся То есть у меня же этот навык
есть я стала дальше зарабатывать таким
образом Был куплен дом купленный
недвижимость и сегодня я должника как бы
собственник полтора миллиона долларов
инвестированных
активах можно сказать Так что история
хорошо закончилась за 7 лет У меня
революция произошла в семье в бизнесе в
личностном росте то есть кредиты где-то
мне помогли
смотрите вообще любые испытания которые
Аллах в этой жизни дает Он же дает мне
зря он дает человек преодолел и вырос
вообще мы растем же как проблема решили
проблему мы выросли решили проблемы
выросли как мы решили проблему небольшой
период отдыха Потом следующая ступенька
и в этом плане это у вас как раз это
система в виде кредитов в исламе еще
есть такое высказывание говорится что
если человек будет заниматься харамным
бизнесом у него даже может получаться но
я сделал так что он не вкусит плодов
этого бизнеса Ну я по банку и своему
также знаю что я с банка например ни
копейки денег не покушал вот вы тоже
сейчас я тоже понимаю что Всевышний меня
оттуда вытащил Потому что сам бизнес был
не созидательный он не созидательный он
был разрушающий бизнес из-за моего
бизнеса люди ссорились мужчины обижали
женщин и я сейчас даже Радуюсь что я вот
в один день оттуда ушла Я быстро
поднималась а потом уже в следующем
бизнесе я спокойно сейчас по часу шла но
вы считаете ключевой фактор это было
знание
Это был мартышки
они зарабатываются умственной энергией
вот эта энергия у меня не было То есть
знаний не было а когда я их получила как
все стало на свои места Круто Круто У
кого есть еще такая история
[смех]
первый Мой кредит был когда вот мы
занимались братом фирм бизнесом на сеть
супермаркетов было и все деньги были в
бизнесе не хватало на просто на жизнь и
банк который у нас обслуживал согласился
выдать мне два кредитных две кредитные
карты
50 тысяч долларов кредитный лимит был на
другом 45 тысяч долларов
И в чем проблема была для меня
оказывается когда вот тебе У тебя есть
95 тысяч долларов кредитного лимита У
тебя есть мнимое ощущение что у тебя
есть Эти деньги я просто потреблять
начал жена говорит надо там съездить в
Дубай с детьми до этого для того чтобы
съездить в Дубая там откладывал с
бизнеса и мы ехали А теперь не вопрос
поехали
[музыка]
что-то купить нам надо мне вопрос
покупаем в Америку Мы поехали Там 30
тысяч долларов потратил так очень быстро
этом 95 тысяч долларов ушло три месяца
четыре полгода
и следующий год
пытался погашать Но как только я погашу
полностью
Да каждый месяц и я понимаю что
во-первых я денег не вижу во-вторых всё
время погашаю погашаю и вот в очередной
раз когда я погасил через год это
полностью эту кредитную линию просто
порезал две карточки искал больше с
кредитными карточками не буду
связываться там можно сказать был
негативный опыт но такое тоже
поучительное что
кредитные деньги они создают тебе мнимое
ощущение что это твои деньги
Ну и хороший опыт тоже был вот машину в
девятнадцатом году взял в кредит был
дорогой обычный там кредит
взял по 2 миллиона в месяц платил это
через год смог всю сумму собрать и отдал
все но в результате машины подорожали Я
даже заработал где-то
Я считаю что такие большие вещи как
машина важная вещь для семьи
максимально брать кредит потому что не
хочется да сразу большую сумму вперед
отдавать Ну то есть смотрите у нас вот
две истории из первой истории можно
сделать вывод что знания очень сильно
помогают
выйти из Долгов из кредитов и так далее
Потому что они оказывают чем надо
заниматься чем не надо заниматься да В
твоем случае очень хороший лайфхак
порезать кредитной карточки потому что
до тех пор пока есть кредитные карточки
у нас создается иллюзия что Это ваши
деньги то есть у меня тоже один из
лайфхаков есть я всегда говорил платить
все время платить
потому что я Когда читал про одну
американскую
очень богатый человек
каждый год 28 декабря он приходил в банк
банкиры ему открывали хранилище в центре
вот такого хранилища вкладывали все его
деньги все его целый куб там сотни
миллионов долларов
готовили ему в углу там Понятно туалет
Там и плюс этот еда все ему его на три
дня закрывали и он три дня брал свои
книги и каждую сделку анализировал
который в течение года все Новый год
отправляли он три года в этом был заперт
банкировал
анализировал каждую сделку и против
каждой сделки смотрите какой
психологический труд против каждой
сделки когда он терял деньги Например
200 тысяч на какое-то сделки он брал 200
тысяч откладывал и прям смотрел сколько
это
вот здесь он потерял там 3 миллиона он
откладывал 3 миллиона и смотрел сколько
это То есть он вот эту виртуальные
Циферки связывался с реальными деньгами
чтобы ему было больно чтобы Прямо
чувство нифига сколько я профукал из-за
своей недобросовестности понимаете и в
конце через три дня таких упражнений
убрал сумку насыпал туда денег Ну чтобы
раздать там бедным родственникам Все
просто насыпал и выходил банка И вот
каждый год он подводил так итоги банкиры
думали что он чуть-чуть это
не в себе но на самом деле это мощнейшая
практика и Вот оттуда я взял практику
говорю чтобы платить
других мыслей что когда конечно платишь
больно
чувствуешь деньги ты чувствуешь что вот
они твои деньги уходят
Режем кредитные карточки у кого долги
это первое что нужно делать как уровень
сказал хорошо Если вы оказались Яме
первое что нужно сделать прекратить
копать дальше
у кого еще ну моя история не такие как
бы
Драматический да то есть я всегда
старался быть терпеливым отношением к
деньгам то есть почти никогда не брал
потребительские кредиты Почему говорю
почти потому что
я брал наверное вспоминаю двух-трех
ситуациях первые Наверное это вот
квартира жилом комплексе или ты можешь
когда бизнес нормально развивался
двигался и просто я брал его анализирую
что мы деньги в бизнесе делают иксы то
есть очень быстро мы развивались и
просто оттуда брать деньги покупать
квартиру не хотелось я тогда первую
квартиру покупал через кредит
благополучно
после этого покупал уже на свои деньги
еще почему говорю почти потому что
я говорил что мы продаем мобильные
телефоны
и я не помню какой год порядка 10 или
больше лет назад активно кредитования
населения электроники А мы в основном
начали продавали то есть аналитику карты
оплачивали или налички приходили и
смотрю дома электроники начали внедрять
Вот это продажи через кредит Ну так как
конкуренция Мы видим что наши продажи
падает Нам тоже это надо внедрять и
тогда что я сделал то есть я пошел
просто торговый дом электроники и купил
себе что-то в кредит чтобы почувствовать
как это вообще делается действительно
Оказывается это делается очень легко
просто так как у меня там мои счета или
как пенсионный там проверять все в
порядке мне сразу выдали этот кредит то
есть получается оказывается легко
поэтому наверное и народ
несколько раз я специально для того
чтобы брать кредит
как-то так еще мы брали кредит для
бизнеса
но я всегда брал для кризиса для бизнеса
только разумный кредит то есть мы
открывали кредитную линию мы видели
рассчитывали что бизнес делает больше и
мы брали и закрывали
порядка 10 лет мы кредитовались и потом
меня сестра финансов директор Давай
кредит Давай То есть она у неё какая-то
нагрузка была а я сильно как-то не
переживал не знаю почему ты женщины
по-другому реагирует или я такой или я
видел цифры мы как-то закрыли и здесь
Наверное через некоторое время
анализирует понял что Иногда помогает Мы
немножко расслабились
в бизнесе разумно брать кредит Наверное
он помогает
когда стоит брать кредит и когда не
стоит наверное обсудим Дальше
он помогает и его история гласит о том
что он брал кредиты но брал кредиты при
условии что бизнес хорошо развивался и
хорошо генерил прибыль То есть он брал
кредиты под бизнес Диас я сталкивался
несколько раз с кредитами долгами Есть
такие Не очень истории Да мы вот не
очень
девять назад мы занимались бизнесом
таким небольшим и
мы брали кредиты для того чтобы залатать
дырки это вообще ужас бесконечная тема
Когда у нас было там где-то 3-4
направления бизнеса автомойки потом были
предложения сайты
Земли санкт-петербург
и у нас был полный рост фокус вот так
как мы такие молодые ребята мы двигались
вдвоем думали то есть то что вот обороты
же есть а прибыли что-то не было То есть
у нас обороты идут оттуда идут оттуда
идут и мы смотрим то что здесь не
хватает денег да давай пойдем кредит
возьмем у нас же есть обороты пошли
евровизийский Взяли кредит залатали
дырки быстренько по зарплате
пришел пришли деньги с контракта там с
мобильного приложения вроде успокоились
потом опять берешь долг потом еще берешь
и теряешь Вот это чувство к деньгам
потому что то есть берем Туда туда
и из-за вот этих вот они дыр ты
во-первых
нету прибыли вообще никакой у нас был
полный раз фокус и не было как у вас
финансовая грамотности
не было никакой финансовой аналитики
ввели по очереди доход и всё вот наша
табличка вся Была весь учет и
это прекратилось только тогда когда мы
просто начали обрубать направление по
бизнесу которые вот просто тащат нас
вниз вот
тогда я вот и потом уже анализировал со
временем то что вот это фокусировка на
Супер важна для как предпринимателя
мы вот нельзя Мы думали деньгами они
думали головой нам надо быстро как
залатать еще бежать дальше
остановиться и подумать Зачем вообще
берем да может быть надо перестроить
вообще формат оплаты труда вот у нас
было там знаете
что-то делают все получают деньги Кроме
нас и даже тогда будет смеялись
[смех]
Я помню один момент когда что-то я мне
даже денег не было помню на такси
поехать поехал на автобусе и такую бегу
на какую-то встречу чтобы контракт
заключить и была еще я тогда жил в
Алматы
знаете иногда покрывается льдом таким
тонким Я такой бегу в костюме
подскользнулся упал в эту грязь такой
лежу
и
тогда это для меня тоже был таким уроком
да то что надо остановиться надо
подтянуть эту финансовую грамотность
[музыка]
всегда можно покушать
и конечно мы у нас тоже есть история с
этим кредитами картами потому что мы
исчерпали все кредитные лимиты по банкам
Да который деньги можно снять тогда
КАСКО выдавали свои карточки такие
красненькие что там сколько лимитов
ходовая там взяли эти карточки а там
нельзя снимать же снимает когда ты
снимаешь у тебя еще больше процентов
выполняя этот набегает мы сняли капец Мы
тоже кажется вроде закидывать потом
опять тратишь и тоже такой лайфхак мы
порезали потом
это бесконечная тема с этой кредитной
карты Ужас из твоей истории можно
сделать два вывода Первое это никогда не
теряйте фокус
над тем чем занимаетесь и второе это
учет
финансов очень важно
ошибка бизнесменов они путают свой
карман с карманом компании и плюс еще
неделя по направлению получается это
направление
какое направление реально их кормит
по-хорошему надо
направление которое кормит а вы
получается
[музыка]
совсем другое в один момент еще было
пять или шесть бизнесов вот так вот и
вообще ужас потом произошел
когда количества бизнесов не есть
количество определений
когда кредиты ты уже когда привыкаешь
что ли не забываешь что это долг который
поступает в этом случае в этом случае
сижу думаю
немножко другая история потому что у нас
бизнес устроен Так что для него
кредитный ресурс Как таковой не нужны в
принципе как и любой
То есть у нас нет большого количества
людей у нас нет большого количества как
это говорилось в Советское
Мы всегда долго считаем Это когда это
человек начнет зарабатывать там когда он
начнет там быть прибыльным и так далее и
условно говоря там любого моего юриста
там я не заходит в Марокко в пустыню
отправь если у него будет ноутбук будет
Связь он будет мне зарабатывать деньги
Ну как любому любому из нас вот это
такая немножко не очень интенсивная
модель она не предполагает там такого
взрывного расширения но очень очень
стабильно
а что касается личного у меня с
кредитной историей тоже есть может быть
Ну как у всех в принципе да собравшихся
сегодня
был более осторожен Нет я на самом деле
я во-первых я любил
Всегда на крупные вещи
там я покупал сначала квартиру
немножко рисковал То есть я всегда
просил у банка максимальные суммы Я
когда например брал кредит на покупку
жилого дома
банк не буду называть но я у этого банка
был крупнейший заемщик физлицо это
причем с начала года причем Это был
сентябрь то есть они мне сказали что
единовременно такой ипотечный кредит они
выдают Ну смысле такого размера в
принципе как бы в первый раз на другое
дело что я всегда понимал как я буду это
возвращать то есть я примерно
знал сроки ни один из моих кредитов не
жил больше трех лет ни один на покупку
автомобиля тоже был
а еще вот одна фишка я всегда
кредитовался
в Казахстане потому что мне удавалось на
девальвациях таких случаях всегда
зарабатывать потому что большинство
наших клиентов иностранные инвесторы и
соответственно наши прибыль она в
основном
доходы в валюте и ты кредитуешься в
тенге это выгодно
и другой банк который я не буду называть
тоже я таким образом хорошо скажем так
мне этот банк подарил много денег
давно оконченные истории потому что
последние ипотеку я закрыл лет шесть
назад но факт что если говорить то
наверное надо знать
в иностранной валюте в Казахстане
наверное что важно Это то что
должен быть на развитие на какой-то рост
не на выживание не на там не на
поддержание штанов условно говоря на
какой-то рост круто круто вот на самом
деле ты хорошая тема поднял Особенно это
касается бизнесменов когда берете кредит
если берете кредит всегда берите только
в тенге желательно под очень низкую
ставку которая сейчас фондому дает по
линии государства которые выдается и
субсидирует состав особенно если у вас
доходы в валюте если у вас доходы валюте
кредиты эта ситуация когда время
работает на вас Чем дольше длиннее
кредит тем больше шансов что он
обесценится
такую ситуацию я
рассматривал два-три проекта где мне
бизнесмены предлагали Один из таких
больших проектов Мне предложили бизнес
который они вложили 45 миллионов
долларов
они мне предлагали
за 10 миллионов долларов Этот бизнес И
когда я начал разбираться бизнесом все
сам по себе очень плохо окупается и
задача была Так что они построили этот
объект за счет двух девальвации у них
кредит Там до 10 миллионов долларов упал
и они там заработали во-первых на
девальвации плюс там прибыль вытащили
что было там и так далее ну Они просто
хотели чтобы остаток кредита я на себя
переписал просто и так далее но сам
бизнес не такой был прибыльный они на
другом заработали но факт то что
бизнесмены зарабатывают до
60-70% От тела кредита то есть
уменьшается за счет девальвации это как
раз тот случай когда если ты взял
длинный кредит и только вопрос времени
когда день варьируется у нас же в
истории не было чтобы долгосрочные
деньги против доллара дороже всегда
дешевле и это закономерно этот яркий
пример Я думаю очень лайфхак всегда если
берете даже в долг кредит всегда берите
только в тенге и только
в этот особенно если у вас доходы валюты
и только на развитие вот как бы опыт
ержана Если говорить про меня то меня
это тоже Многие спрашивают по поводу
Правды кредит беру ли кредит Конечно я
брал кредит я брал много кредитов в
разные времена у меня была проблема что
другого характера в 94 году у меня
кинула моя команда и меня оставила с
кредитом 12 миллионов долларов перед
каскамерцбанком команда От меня ушла и
забрала все активы кстати компания потом
стала номер один в мире эта компания
Алиби зерновая компания так вот зерновая
компания Алиби это CMR это все активы
которые у меня забрали в своё время
[музыка]
долларов мы вложили в компанию Они ушли
но потом они сами обанкротились
Ну до этого они выросли до номер один но
факт что я брал кредиты на развитие брал
кредит на бизнес но произошел форс-мажор
меня кинули ребята я юридически
неправильно оформил активы в результате
остался с 12 с половиной миллионов
долларов и тут хотел бы внести свою
лепту в
лайфхаки по кредитам
что я понял я понял одно я понял что я
один что у меня шансов нет Первое что я
делал я пошел в казкоммерцбанка кредит
был перед казком выложил все как есть и
сказал что я им кредит вернул только
Дайте мне отсрочку
свести проценты и дайте мне новый лимит
Я верну
и мы договорились
построил уже дальше завод я начал
строить
[музыка]
на тот момент
за счет того что я начал строить заводы
сразу залог
[музыка]
заберете себе
и таким образом я закрыл 12 миллионов
долларов кредит последние остатки я
закрыл когда продал Казахстан Карага
ребята Я построил два Кожев зовут и
комбинация Казахстан харзы Но
какой лайфхак проблема большинства людей
в том что люди считают что кредит это
что-то такое Вот вот знаете как как
налоговая Соединенных Штатов все это
только смерть и налоги этот то что в
этом мире не меняется и то что нужно
заплатить вы эту парадигму должны убрать
убеждение нужно убрать
кредит это всегда на той стороне
кредитор и кредитор хочет вернуть деньги
Он не хочет вас уничтожить он не хочет
вас убить он не хочет вас унизить он
просто тупо хочет вернуть свои деньги
Поэтому если вы будете убегать он будет
преследовать Если вы будете хитрить он
будет всячески вам поставить препятствия
А если вы идете кредитору выкладывайте
все как есть на стол и показываете
искреннее намерение вернуть кредит но
показывайте что у вас нет возможности то
вместе с кредитором Вы можете составить
какой-то план как вы можете вернуть этот
кредит то есть рассматривать кредитора
как помощника не как врага проблема
большинства в том что люди воспринимают
кредиторы как врага И соответственно
никаких переговоры с ним не ведут А вот
этот первый кредит меня научил тому что
если я вижу что
я делаю Я иду кредитору и договаривались
части либо сни стопроцентной ставки либо
об отсрочке Но точно я помощь первую
помощь Я всегда ищу у кредитора всегда
можно договориться всегда всегда у меня
даже были ситуации когда я задолжал
Ну
это по Московскому банку и Они прислали
мне бандитов
прислали бандит те времена это дело
столько так и делалось так как процент
были большие
3 миллиона долларов
и в это время получилось так что моего
брата подстрелили
[музыка]
Так мы в одном бизнесе
они сказали Мы останавливаем проценты
вернёте когда сможете все И это Мы не
просили Не торговались ними ничего
просто я искренне показывал да я осознаю
да до брат брал Ну и что Но я за него в
ответе когда Он выздоровеет Я не знаю но
я буду делать все чтобы вернуть в
результате Я получил такое сообщение что
вернете когда сможете Почему они такое
решение приняли как думаете а какой у
них был вариант
не было То есть списать они не могут
писать они не могут
а с другой стороны
бесполезно крутить проценты на проценты
кроме Бесполезно Бесполезно отнимать
что-то бесполезно убивать тем более
бессмысленно
соответственно какой у них выход и вот
они сказали вернете когда сможете в
развитие этой темы на той теме что надо
работать с кредитом по сути надо
работать кредитом из кредитором еще одна
есть недооцененная сильная тема
рефинансирования вот я рефинансировал
два кредита в жизни и причем там я не
знаю у одного банка он не выдал в
ипотеку там 14 процентов я смотрю там
другого 12
потому что это кажется вот эти два
процента это ерунда перспективе там двух
там трёх лет нормальные суммы они всегда
нормально Это хорошо идут а у нас люди
обычно действительно они там берут
кредиты они его забывают они просто его
выплачивают или просто ставят что там
что-то списывалось
гибкая штука достаточно с ним можно
работать
человек который знаете
анекдоты расскажу когда
[музыка]
ходит по дому бессонница и так далее ему
говорит жена сарасе чего не спишь Он
говорит Да вот у мошек взял в долг 100
тысяч долларов и не знаю как вернуть она
берет мощь мощь берет набирает мощный
мощь А если у тебя брал кредит за 100
тысяч добрал в долг так вот он не
собирается возвращать Бросил трубку
теперь пусть он не спит
то же самое всегда помните кредитор это
первое лицо заинтересованное в вашем
благополучии после того конечно как мы
получили кредит потому что до этого
если вы попали в трудную ситуацию то
лучше общаться с ним
продолжение этой темы
отрицательных эмоций по отношению ко мне
он мне не давал развиваться он не давал
идти это вот все и я с каждым
индивидуальным разговаривала я говорила
Ты же меня знаешь да ты же знаешь мою
работоспособность Да вот что мне нужно
мне нужно чтобы ты по-доброму ко мне
относился и дал время ты знаешь что я
отработаю эта ситуация она выравниваемая
только дай мне время я индивидуально с
каждым разговаривала и вот когда они
ментально меняют отношения к тебе а ты
начинаешь чуть не по 50 долларов
возвращать им даже по 50 если это
продолжается три месяца подряд
одно и то же время приносишь 50 долларов
примерно и говоришь вот я принесла
пожалуйста поставь подпись у меня знаете
ошибок было я кучу денег давала но нигде
не могла это потом доказать не
фиксировала это было настолько Это я
работала знаете не на бизнес-анализе она
эмоциональном уровне
все джентльменское соглашение там все
верят мне я верю всем а в итоге все люди
какие-то люди отказались Но это видимо
урок для меня был И когда ты уже ты
после трех месяцев у меня знаете прям
все пошло как по маслу Потому что люди
поменяли свою агрессивное отношение ко
мне уже совсем по-другому
уже молятся за тебя
приходила прям говорила давай сядем
сейчас ты мысленно против меня вот что
ты хочешь чтобы я испепелилась или я
умерла Что ты хочешь Я не хочу я говорю
ты хочешь чтобы я тебе Вернула деньги
время у меня маленькие дети я не ради
тебя я ради своих детей это буду делать
ради их будущего ты понимаешь я мама и я
им говорила Ты должен я верю И когда ты
начинаешь по чуточку ежемесячно в одно и
то же время они уже меняют к тебе
отношение А это уже сказывается на твоём
росте и на твоём развитии еще я хотела
Ты должен Бога благодарить когда у тебя
дела идут они искать его тогда когда
тебе плохо А у нас у всех же наоборот я
поняла вот бизнес ты открываешь и у тебя
идет рост оборот там видимость Да
иллюзия бизнеса и вот когда ты доходишь
до какого-то определенного Пика все
думают что всегда будет так если в это
время бизнесмен не расширяет свои знания
и не расширяет свой бизнес он придет в
состояние упадка
Вот вы сейчас сказали то что упало
поднять Всегда трудно поэтому я
сейчас знаю что есть умные кредиты Есть
глупые кредиты и для меня умные кредиты
это когда ты берешь на расширение
бизнеса на пополнение оборотных средств
и еще мне нравится выражение
если статья будет платить другие
купила квартиру в ипотеку сдала и пусть
платят людей А ты спокойно через
какое-то время люди ты помогаешь идем
решать вопрос жилья
а они платят твой кредит и в итоге ты в
плюсе остаешься я считала что глупый
кредит это на твой брать на технику
брать потому что машина что же может
сломаться машина тоже может сломаться а
сейчас ситуация Ильяса показала мне что
он крутую тачку купил и в итоге выиграл
получается деньги даже выиграли то есть
иногда можно идти на короткие финансовый
риск чтобы получить больше он получается
[музыка]
на крутую тачку но в тенге за счет
девальвации
[смех]
которые тормозили мое развитие на семь
новых привычек и произошла
в моей жизни
привычки Мы все знаем что нужно утром
вставать Мы все знаем что пить нельзя
например но мы не делаем это А вот когда
ты привычку вот здесь Нейрон сложился
если я курю постоянно примерно Я не курю
но вот этот Нейрон мне всегда будет
говорить Курень кури и мне нужно его
заменить чем-то привычки просто так не
уходят их нужно обязательно вот я когда
поменяла 7 привычек произошел Квантовый
скачок Я своим э кто ко мне приходит на
консультацию Я им говорю
автомобиль
интересно я недавно от двух бизнесменов
слышал две противоречивые вещи Ну они не
противоречивы А как бы такие смотрите
Один говорит
Сейчас у меня бизнес хорошо идёт Всё
прибыль всё приносит я кайфую но я вижу
что я и команда мы начали сдуваться
а когда у меня проблемы Я зверь два-три
раза эффективнее Я говорю всё рву Я
говорит Мне прям мне хочется что-то я
всегда расту когда мне трудно когда
проблемы когда долги и так далее Это
один случай Да
второй случай парень говорит Марина вот
Я сейчас бизнес наладил У меня все
хорошо
и вот Деньги приходят с бизнеса А я их
все раскидываю все время теряю все время
вот как избавиться от этой супер
щедрости
долг просит ему отдам тому отдам кто-то
проект Я всегда делаю так что у меня
денег не осталось вот такой
психологический
теперь Подходим к вопросу Давайте или
нет давать долг вот
основная проблема то что его просят И он
не может отказать
[музыка]
В итоге на красный диплом закончила и я
всегда давала всегда помогала но когда
вот знания получила что вот это вот как
бы Понты что ты крутая что ты можешь
помочь что ты как бы вот твое эго я села
проанализировала все собрала всех
родственников накрыла хорошие Дастархан
и сказала вот До сегодняшнего дня я вам
всем помогала никогда никому не
отказывала у меня дети маленькие у меня
оказалось что у меня крупные кредиты
давайте сделаем так сегодняшнего дня
кран закрывается я не могу вам больше
помогать Не просите меня я не могу вам
говорить Нет потому что мама умирая всех
поручила почему-то мне и у меня вот это
вот чувство ответственности есть но у
меня есть свои дети ваши дети все
выросли Я думала младше давайте сделаем
так даром всё хорошо
Оставьте меня и я буду как бы свои долги
закрывать потому что мои дети растут То
есть я вот так переговоры провела я
поняла
То есть это как бы я читала одного
английского бизнесмена он говорит 100
человек одинаково зарабатывает из них 20
могут сохранить а четыре приумножить то
есть эти 20 людей знают правила о
деньгах а четыре эти правила применяют в
жизни другие просто тратят и я ещё
говорит
избавьтесь от тех паразитов которые вас
всегда просят деньги то есть мои
родственники не паразиты мои самые
трудные дни они мне помогали были рядом
они меня вытащили но я им сказала все с
пониманием отнеслись все как бы это ну
вот чтобы они приезжаешь ты всегда щедро
давала идея тем нашим это а тут ему
когда я вот зато за два с половиной года
потому что все ненужные расходы были
сокращены Вот это моё самое главное я
сократила все ненужные расходы увеличила
стратегию вот я три вещи Может быть
кому-то интересно будет инструменты
знать первое Я изменила мышление от
должника
я формировала мышление победителя
миллионера второе я
стратегию увеличения доходов Как я могу
увеличить доходы чем я могу быть
полезной Оказывается он по мне столько
много что может принести мне деньги а я
все ходила в банке новый кредиты брала у
меня было мышление должника И третье Я
поставила нищета слова не считать
строгий учет всем своим денежным
расходом
смотрите у казахов как 300 зарабатываешь
на 300 живешь 500 зарабатываешь на 500
800 зарабатываешь уже на тысячу живешь
Мы всегда тратим больше чем зарабатываем
это вот наша фишка И вот я научилась
жить на 300 при том что я зарабатывал
уже полтора раза больше
три года своей семье сказала Давайте три
года будем жить так как надо а потом
будем жить так как хочу
[музыка]
четырнадцатого года я регулярно давал
любым кто кредит кредит и они регулярно
возвращались
придет друг скажет можешь мне дать там
50 тысяч долларов на три дня я даю через
три дня он возвращает придет родственник
скажет там тайне 50 тысяч долларов у
меня тендер мне надо закупиться и вот
выплатят через месяц отдам родственник
задаешь где-то после 14 года резко все
что я выдал перестала возвращаться
система сломалась Да я понял что
начали там из дома там жена говорит Я же
тебе говорил не давать ты меня не слушал
всегда
человек возвращал
ты С тех пор я просто поменял мышление Я
сказал что я дам только ту сумму которую
я дам практически как на
благотворительность
вот и это уже не 50 тысяч долларов это
2000 долларов и все Я не ожидаю что их
вернут
У меня тоже основная проблема была в том
что тяжело говорить Нет знакомы друзьям
родственникам и у меня больше просили Не
деньги хотя и деньги тоже просят и до
сих пор просят и просили больше просили
телефоны
в рассрочку телефон
в начале действительно многие оплачивали
на три месяца на 6 месяцев Главное чтобы
закрывал то есть и по скидки в рассрочку
а потом какие-то годы начала
происходить что список
как вообще это что такое то есть
психологический ментально немножко
меняться и
здесь как раз один анекдоты из которой я
хочу рассказать даже реально такие даже
случаи были у меня тоже самое сейчас
аналогия идут ну допустим там
Мурат у Серика допустим взял деньги 100
тысяч долларов и по истечении например
на 6 месяцев По истечению времени не
возвращает он приходит что-то не
возвращайся
немножко пока не получается скоро
вернуться не получается Проходит время
не возвращает он приходит когда вернешь
ладно пусть не сто тысяч долларов будет
я же понимаю тебя хотя бы 90 тысяч
долларов Вернее что у тебя не получается
хорошо проходит еще два-три месяца он
опять к нему возвращается когда вернешь
Ну опять рассказывать что пока не
получается Хотя бы там 70.000 долларов
ладно тебе списывают всё в 70.000
долларов
это повторяется и в третий раз когда
четвёртый раз когда приходит когда
вернусь это черная жесть потихоньку
возвращаешь
У меня возникали ситуации когда у меня
брали в рассрочку телефоны и там не
возвращает долгое время А что до сих пор
не писал что ли
Это же деньги или Последний кусок
доедаешь
в те времена я сам брал часто в долг на
именно на бизнес может и когда кредиты
еще были Ну допустим взяли эти кредиты А
еще нужно были деньги я шёл тоже друзья
брал долг
это был только в тот период больше не
сталкивался этим потому что
также то есть одно время также давал
долг Но потом как-то сложилось такое
общее мнение связи с развитием интернет
что все Сейчас многие мои Так что даешь
долг то то что не жалко короче то что
даже вот не вернут Ладно короче и
поэтому если удалось меня просят есть
или он тебе на неделю там что-то у него
вот такой я могу только 100 вот если
тебе это как-то поможет там то у
десятерых возьмешь по 100 да Или кто-то
тебе 900 дал тебе что не хватает вот
можешь обратиться ко мне у меня такой
как бы лайфхак скажем по этим долгам
у меня Никаких особенных Нет я честно
говоря всегда
в таких случаях стараюсь помочь
[музыка]
Спасибо Когда долг не возвращен то
бегать никому неприятно условно
от кого-то это всегда воспринимается и
человек воспринимается по-другому и
никому не хочется ходить с такой
репутацией поэтому не сталкивался но я
вот связи с тем что обсуждалось вспомнил
один анекдот Я даже не знаю можно ли это
анекдот на этом подкастером я думаю
можно
даже не анекдот
это мы с друзьями
[музыка]
Поехали на природу с ночевкой поставили
палатки
взяли с собой то что в таких случаях
полагается
близкий он как всегда в таких случаях по
утрам не очень хорошем физическом
состоянии он говорит вот послушай вот мы
взяли 5 бутылок выпили 5 Взяли бы 10
выпили бы 10 Как это работает Вот точно
также здесь живешь зарабатываешь 300
живешь на 300 зарабатываешь на 500
зарабатывает
взяли 10 выпили 10
в следующий раз где-то надо взять 20
лет у нас денег не хватило он говорит А
зачем мы взяли продукты
вообще смотрите
хорошие
вырисовался такой лайфхак из того что я
послушал ваши истории смотрите то
Насколько часто у вас берут в долг и
Насколько часто возвращают зависит от
среды
вот Ержан Он общается как правило с
юристами общается с людьми образованными
ответственными Понятно Эти люди у нее в
долг и не берут потому что понимают что
долг это ответственность это договор это
залог ну какие-то такие процедуры и так
далее немножко не так немножко не так мы
вот та компания в которой я как бы есть
мы друг другу даем с удовольствием
просто потому что мы 22 года уже как бы
отношения Мы точно знаем
но этой компании которая
заметил такую вещь что среда когда тянет
назад
Каким образом помимо того что говорит Да
зачем тебе надо Что ты будь осторон
посадить Зачем тебе бизнес нужен помимо
этих слов тянет таким образом что они
приходят бесконечно просят либо помощь
либо в долг
и не возвращает и таким образом тянут
Тебя назад поэтому очень внимательно
Будьте к своей среде если Хотите
избавиться от долгов Я бы так сказал что
первое что нужно сделать Поменяйте среду
и среда вам поможет выбраться из Долгов
это
так сказал даже ну не первое одно из
первых потому что первое Я говорю
Перестаньте брать новые долги прежде
кредитной карточки Ну вот одно из один
из лайфхаков это Поменяйте среду потому
что когда правильная среда она сама
помогает вылезти Долгов это всегда ты
среду спортсменов попадешь тебе легче
ходить на тренировки
пойдешь в среду пинаре они будут
говорить где нужно там начнут куча
мудрости говорит о том что
друзья не считается за счет жизни
Как китайцы говорят когда ученик готов
учиться всегда найдется Я надеюсь в этой
части мы были полезны по крайней мере
нашей истории а мы продолжаем дальше
[музыка]